so we have to just realize at this point
that the Washington Post does not like
Bernie Sanders from an editorial
perspective and they're clearly involved
in a Bernie smear operation even if not
completely deliberate by sort of default
this is what they are doing so I want to
look at the Washington Post coverage of
Bernie but I also want to look back at
the back and forth about the Washington
Post's coverage of Bernie which actually
maybe tells us even more so the first
thing is does the Washington Post do a
bunch of anti Bernie coverage the answer
is yes that's okay
they're allowed to let's look at some of
the stories this is just a list of
stories from back in March of 2016
during a two-day period 16 negative
stories about Bernie including some
stories implying Bernie is some kind of
misogynist to Hillary Clinton
racializing some headlines about Bernie
focusing on White States calling Bernie
partisan so this is undeniably a very
anti Bernie set of stories at a very key
moment in the 2016 primary and it has
continued if we look at the recent
couple of months the Washington Post ran
a story about Iowa doesn't like Bernie
anymore
Bernie looking to Canada for affordable
drug drugs like insulin doesn't really
make sense
the NRA helped elect Bernie and Bernie
won't admit it
Bernie is running into a quote socialist
reality that is interfering with his
ideas I mean just persistently hammering
away at Bernie so Bernie did the right
thing he spoke up and he said something
and the Washington Post has responded in
a really silly way completely straw
Manning Bernie's complaint Bernie said
the Post writes negative things about me
a lot this is demonstrably true I mean
it's just a fact and the Washington
Post's executive editor martin baron
came back and said oh Bernie's claiming
with no evidence that Jeff Bezos is
telling us to write bad things about
Bernie Jeff Bezos has nothing to do with
the day-to-day decisions editorially of
the Washington Post wait a sec what Jeff
Bezos what are you talking about okay
the Washington Post is owned by Amazon
Jeff Bezos runs Amazon but Bernie wasn't
saying that Jeff Bezos is calling The
Washington Post
and saying write bad things about
Bernie Sanders so the Washington Post is
arguing against something Bernie never
claimed but there is still something
really important to understand here in a
lot of news outlets that have bias you
will often hear this argument no one's
telling me what to write therefore there
is no institutional bias here you hear
this all the time on Fox News Fox News
reporters no one tells me no one
upstairs tells me exactly what to say we
me when my producers figure out what to
say I and my producers when you hear
from current or former RT people RT
being Russian state television RT
anchors will say I have total freedom
here no one comes to me and says you've
got to do this or you've got to say that
or defend Putin or whatever that's not
how it works that's an extremely
childish understanding of how it works
people are hired because they are being
selected for what it is they are going
to do RT anchors are hired not so that
they can be told what to do but because
they wouldn't need to be told they are
selected to fill a certain role same
thing on Fox News and the Washington
Post
you know Bernie never claimed Bezos is
telling people what to write but the way
it works is that the newsroom is
assembled to get people writing what it
is that the Washington Post wants
written it could be Bezos or someone
else who is making the general call
about what the attitude is going to be
or not but this is the way it works the
reporters writing the stuff at the
Washington Post most likely don't need
to be told write negative stuff about
Bernie at the end of the day none of
this is surprising the Washington Post
has done really good investigative stuff
in the Trump era and that's good and we
can praise them for it at the same time
when it comes to the DEM primary the
Washington Post is demonstrably and
reliably anti Bernie in their coverage
of Democratic primaries okay we know
that we should be scrutinizing
everything that we take in in terms of
media this show included but we can't
deny that without getting into bezos's
calling The Washington Post editorial e
has been consistently anti Bernie period
and Bernie's right to call that out